bien mes chers
collègues nous poursuivons notre matinée
consacrée à la préparation de l'examen
de la proposition de loi relative au
service express régionaux métropolitain
cerme qui est inscrite à l'ordre du jour
de la séance publique du 23 octobre
prochain après l'audition du président
du directeur du directoire de la Société
du Grand Paris nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir Mathieu Chabanel président
directeur général de SNCF réseau SNCF
réseau en tant que gestionnaire du
réseau feré national jouera sans aucun
doute un rôle fondamental dans la
conception et la réalisation des projets
SERMES votre entreprise est d'ailleurs
s'est d'ailleurs penché sur cette
question depuis plusieurs années le
rapport annexé à la loi d'orientation
des mobilités l'homme de décembre 2019
Ava en effet confié à SNCF réseau le
soin de présenter au gouvernement un
plan d'ensemble sur la désaturation des
grands nœuds ferroviaires aussi le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure a publié
en octobre 2020 un schéma directeur des
étoiles ferroviaires et service express
métropolitain qui a mis en avant le fort
potentiel de développement des SM et
souligner la nécessité d'investissement
massif pour réaliser ces projets les
projets consisteront pour une part non
négligeable en des aménagements
conséquents de modernisation et
d'amélioration des capacités d'ouvrage
ferroviaire existant or ce réseau
esttant en France
vieillissant les petites lignes du
quotidien en particulier ont été
délaissé pendant de nombreuses années et
exige non seulement dans le cadre des
CERMES mais partout ailleurs d'être
rénové SNCF réseau assurera la maîtrise
d'ouvrage de ses travaux sur les lignes
existantes dans le cadre des CERMES et
pourrait bien entendu assurer également
celle des nouvelles
infrastructure monsieur le Président
comment comptez-vous relever le défi de
cette nouvelle impulsion en
faveur des transports ferroviaire du
quotidien dans notre pays dans ce
contexte difficile SNCF réseau a-t-il
les moyens de mener à bien tant de
projets simultanés et de répondre à ce
véritable mur
d'investissement par ailleurs notre
échange avec Monsieur Montel nous a
montré combien le nouveau rôle dévolue à
la future société des grands projets qui
pourra notamment être maître d'ouvrage
des projets de cerme pour la réalisation
de nouvelles infrastructures
ferroviaires et novateures cette
situation inédite peut susciter des
interrogation commentnc Fréau compte
donc gérer cette situation nouvelle de
coexist
avec la SGP sur la maîtrise d'ouvrage
d'infrastructure destiné à être intégré
au réseau ferré national je ne serereai
pas plus long et vous cède sans plus
tarder la parole pour un propos
liminaire d'une quinzaine de minutes
avant de laisser mes collègues à
commencer par le rapporteur philippe
Tabarot rapporteur de la proposition de
loi vous posez les questions et la
question que j'imagine nombreuse je vous
cède la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et et et
sénateurs je suis je suis très heureux
d'être d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir vous présenter les
orientations de SNCF réseau vis-à-is de
C je vous ai coupé en enlevant attendez
je vais arrêter
mon c'est bon vous m'entendez voilà je
suis très heureux d'être d'être parmi
vous aujourd'hui pour pouvoir vous
présenter les les orientations de de
SNCF réseau vis-à-vis de de cette
proposition de loi autour des des
services express régionaux
métropolitains services express
régionaux métro litain dont dont vous le
disiez monsieur le Président nous avons
la conviction à SNCF réseau depuis
longtemps qu'ils sont une une réponse
adaptée à des besoins nombreux des
besoins de décarbonation des transports
des besoins de lutte contre la
congestion dans les air métropolitaines
mais aussi des besoins de liens social
entre les territoires notamment les
territoires périurbain avec le le cœur
des métropoles et que dans ces ces zones
situées entre 30 et 80 K komè du cœur
des métropoles le train offre un moyen
de lien accessible ouvert et efficace
euh et SNCF réseau est engagé dans ce
sujet des services express m régionaux
métropolitains alors qui qui ont qui ont
changé de nom au cours du temps mais la
proposition de loi consacre cette
appellation qui me semble très adaptée
est engagée depuis longtemps puisque
vous le rappeliez nous avons remis euh
dans le cadre de des demandes faites au
travers de la loi d'orientation sur la
mobilité un rapport qui a posé les
principes qui aujourd'hui euh conduisent
au développement euh de de de ces de ces
services alors il me semble important de
revenir sur le fait que ce sont d'abord
des services et c'est avant d'être des
infrastructures et que l'enjeu premier
c'est bien d'offrir un service et de
partir de l'offre de transport et et et
du besoin d'offre de transport défini
euh par les collectivités régionales et
métropolitaines euh avant de parler euh
infrastructure l'enjeu c'est bien
d'offrir le le meilleur service à nos
concitoyens et pour ça de s'appuyer sur
des gammes de solutions qui peuvent
aller de l'augmentation du service
ferroviaire sur le réseau existant à la
construction de nouvelles
infrastructures quand quand ce réseau ne
permet pas de répondre à ce besoin à ce
besoin d'offre de transport mais il y a
déjà souvent de premières étapes qu'on
peut faire en mettant des trains plus
tard des trains plus fr
plus de trains le weekend et et dont on
voit qui répondent aujourd'hui à la
pétence pour pour pour le
train comment se rendre le samedi pour
faire ses courses au cœur de la
métropole en prenant le train plutôt que
la voiture c'est c'est d'abord une
question de fréquence avant d'être une
question d'infrastructure
d'infrastructure nouvelle deuxième enjeu
qui qui me semble essentiel c'est que ce
service express régional métropolitain
il est par nature
multimodale il y a pas une excl
exclusivité du ferroviaire les systèmes
de car Express les systèmes de transport
urbain naturellement les systèmes de
mobilité douce ou active doivent trouver
toute leur place dans cette combinaison
qui qui qui répond qui répond aux
besoins et aux attentes de de nos
concitoyens le ferroviaire est sans
doute une colonne vertébrale et c'est
pour ça qu'il est au cœur de la
proposition de loi qu'il est et qu'il
peut structurer ses déplacements mais
mais je pense un important de de penser
et de concevoir l'ensemble de de ces
aspects il y a des axes où il y a pas
aujourd'hui de réseau ferroviaire et où
des services de car peuvent au moins
dans un premier temps répondre répondre
à la à la à la demande je vous précise
tout de suite que SNCF réseau ne se
positionne pas pour s'occuper des
services de de de car
euh donc vous vous l'avez compris euh
notre enjeu c'est d'abord un enjeu de
service et et lié à cet enjeu de service
va se poser très très vite la la
question de la qualité du service qui
sera qui sera rendu et et et c'est pour
cela de la de de penser dès la
conception de ces services express
régionaux métropolitains la manière dont
ils seront exploités de manière à ce
qu'on puisse offrir la qualité de
service qui est attendu parce que un
service express régional métropolitain
qui se met en place et qui ne répond pas
aux attentes ou qui offre ou qui
dysfonctionne même dans un premier temps
on a vu que ça pouvait nuir à à
l'ambition qui a été portée par les
collectivités régionales et
métropolitaines donc il faut vraiment
qu'on pense ces sujets
d'exploitation très en amont dès la
définition et et et et la proposition de
loi à ce titre pose bien ce sujet de
voilà on pense au service on pense à
l'exploitation et on pense à la qualité
de l'exploitation et en matière de
qualité d'exploitation SNCF réseau aura
tout son rôle à la fois comme acteur
mais aussi comme j'allais dire garant
que le service qu'on envisage dans un
site donné il il est bien faisable et il
faudra savoir parfois dire bien non avec
ces infrastructures là on peut pas
mettre ces trains en plus faute de quoi
on dégraderait on dégraderait la qualité
c'est aussi notre responsabilité qu'on
doit apprendre à mieux exercer dans le
temps aussi bien du côté de SNCF réseau
que du du côté de gare et connexion vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président la la
la grande nouveauté introduite par la
par la proposition de loi au-delà de ce
travail Ess de de définition et et de
mise en place d'un cadre de coopération
c'est l'intervention de la la Société du
Grand Paris deain Société des grands
projets au côté des autres acteurs et au
côté de SNCF réseau SNCF gare et
connexion dans dans la la l'ensemble des
des problématiques relatives à ces
services express régionaux
métropolitains alors du point de vue de
SNCF réseau nous voyons d'un bon œil
même d'un très bon œil cette perspective
de coopération avec un avec un nouvel
acteur nous le voyons d'un d'un bon œil
parce que il nous semble que vu
l'ampleur de l'ambition qui est posée
autour des services express régionaux
métropolitain on Nura pas trop de toutes
les bonnes volontés et de toutes les
compétences pour réussir à à à relever à
relever ce défi la société des du Grand
Paris demain société des grands projets
mais son président vous l'a exposé
possède des compétences en matière de
concertation en matière d'infrastructure
neuvve en matière d'ingénierie
financière pour financer ces projets qui
sont des compléments très intéressants
au aux compétences que que SNCF réseau
ou SNCF gare et connexion peuvent
peuvent apporter et la proposition de
loi de notre point de vue présente un un
une position équilibrée sur le périmètre
d'intervention vous savez que j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'exprimer publiquement à
de nombreuses reprises que pour les les
travaux sur le réseau exploité
c'est-à-dire les travaux sur le réseau
sur lequel circule déjà aujourd'hui des
trains nous considérons qu'il c'est un
enjeu à la fois de sécurité et de
qualité de service que ce soit SNCF
réseau qui qui réalise ses travaux en
revanche sur les infrastructures
nouvelles et nous l'avons démontré à
plusieurs reprises quand on a construit
un certain nombre de lignes à grande
vitesse quand on a conduit un certain
nombre de projets sur les
infrastructures nouvelles nous pensons
que l'on peut tout à fait travailler
avec un nouvel acteur qui construit ses
infrastructures nouvelles avec un
travail de en amont de bonne définition
de comment ces infrastructures nouvelles
sont construites comment on les
maintiendra comment on les exploitera
mais on sait faire cela on le fait en
Île-de-France déjà avec la Société du
Grand Paris qui construit ses
infrastructures nouvelles qui sont
souvent en interaction avec les
infrastructures ferroviaires du réseau
ferré national et et ça se passe bien on
a réussi de de nombreuses opérations de
garde interconnexion entre le réseau
ferré national et le le nouveau réseau
du Grand Paris et les opérations se sont
se sont bien passé et donc j'ai j'ai
j'ai pas de doute qu'on réussira à
travailler de de manière constructive
on a une relation de longue date avec
Jean-François monteis qui est très qui
est très fluide et et et et on a aucune
intention de jouer une carte
concurrentielle mais plutôt une carte de
la de la de la complémentarité euh donc
l'équilibre de la de la de la qui a été
tracé dans la proposition de loi nous
nous paraît nous paraît bien bien
articulé il nous semble qu'il faut
vraiment que ces services express
régionaux métropolitains puissent
trouver leur modalités pro
de de fonctionnement territoire par
territoire c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est un enjeu essentiel parce que
territoire par territoire on va pas
avoir les mêmes acteurs et territoire
par territoire on va pas avoir les mêmes
problématiques et donc il faut que la
proposition de loi et elle le fait
aujourd'hui laisse la souplesse
nécessaire à une définition territoriale
sous l'autorité de ceux qui vont porter
le projet c'est-à-dire les autorités
organisatrices régionales et
métropolitaines et et et
l'État les les modalités de définition
et et
d'organisation de de de ces service
donc il y a naturellement quelques
propositions consensuelles avec la
Société du Grand Paris je le précise qui
qui pourrait de de notre point de vue
enrichir ou plutôt préciser la
proposition de loi autour de de la de la
remise des biens une fois qu'ils ont été
construits autour du du du rôle de de de
coordination et notamment de la
possibilité
ouverte que les que les groupements
d'intérêt public qui sont un peu au cœur
de cette coordination puissent être des
structures à directoire et conseil de
surveillance il nous semble que ce
serait quelque chose d'intéressant qui
permettrait aux collectivités de trouver
toute leur place dans dans dans un
conseil de surveillance mais voilà il y
a on a quelques quelques propositions
mais qui ne remettent pas en cause
l'équilibre l'équilibre de la de la
proposition de de de loi et et et voilà
on s'inscrit vraiment du côté de SNCF
réseau à la fois dans cette dynamique je
je voyais en entrant l'exposition sur
Charles de Fressinet voilà je pense
qu'on est de nouveau dans un temps du
ferroviaire dans lequel on peut avoir
une une croissance une dynamique de
développement du ferroviaire qui qui
rejoignent celle qui a qui qui a pu
exister par le par le passé et donc on
s'inscrit résolument dans cette
dynamique avec la conviction que les
services express régionaux
métropolitains sont une bonne méthode et
la conviction que le travail
complémentaire entre les entités du
groupe SNCF et la SGP peut-être un
accélérateur de des services express
régionaux métropolitains voilà monsieur
le Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices que
je pouvais indiquer en
introduction merci merci je vais donc
donner la parole à notre rapporteur
philippe
Tabarot monsieur le Président merci mes
chers collègues si je peux me permettre
avant de commencer mon mon propos après
moi les collègues bien sûr auront
l'occasion de s'exprimer et de vous
poser un certain nombre de questions si
je peux leur passer un petit message et
me permettre exceptionnellement pas de
leur donner des consignes mais mais
simplement de rappeler que on est dans
le cadre d'une audition concernant un
texte bien particulier qui est le texte
des CERMES je sais que vous brûlez
d'impatience de poser des questions au
président Chabanel sur vos lignes de
dessert F de territoire dans vos
départements respectifs
essayons de rester sur le sujet et je ne
doute pas un instant que comme il l'a
toujours fait monsieur Chabanel
reviendra dans quelques semaines pour
venir parler de nos territoires et et
donc peut-être même s'il termine et si
vous ne l'abreuvez pas de questions il
pourra consacrer un petit temps en off
pour vous donner des nouvelles de de de
vos lignes ferroviaires respectives euh
chers collègues SNCF réseau doit
aujourd'hui répondre à de nombreux défis
lui faut rattraper le retard accumulé
dans l'entretien dans la modernisation
du réseau tout en lançant de nouveaux
programmes d'investissement euh
l'article 1er de la Lomme rapporté avec
talent dans cette maison par Didier
Mandelli a fixé de nouveaux objectif à
la stratégie de l'État pour les
mobilités en particulier celui de
renforcer les offres de déplacement du
quotidien cela exige notamment selon ce
même article de résorber la saturation
des grandes nœuds ferroviaires afin de
doubler la part modale du transport
ferroviaire dans les grands pôles
urbains le développement des ces
s'inscrit dans la continuité de ses
objectifs comme l'a indiqué le président
longjot SNCF réseau a participé dans son
étude de 2020 consacré aux étoiles
ferroviaires et service express
métropolitain la conception des projets
de cerme cette étude a montré la très
grande ampleur des investissements à
réaliser or vous devez pour ainsi dire
courir plusieurs lièvres à la fois
concomitamment avec ces projets de cerme
il vous faut mener de grands projets
d'envergure je pense NOTAM amment à GPSO
certains autres projets qui ont vocation
à s'inscrire dans les CERMES et je pense
bien sûr à la
LNPCA pouvez-vous préciser quelle est la
stratégie des SNCF réseau pour répondre
à cette situation comment vous
adaptez-vous à ce changement de
paradigme assurez assumez-vous un virage
en faveur des mobilités du quotidien que
vous privilégiez le cas échéant à la
ligne aux lignes à grande vitesse quit
du fr ferroviaire qui est un sujet qui
nous intéresse tous également le temps
industriel en général et ferroviair en
particulier est un temps long comme vous
le savez mais la demande pour des
infrastructures de transport décarboné
de qualité est extrêmement
pressente la présente proposition de loi
fixant l'état du texte un objectif qui
est très ambitieux de mise en place d'au
moins une dizaine de de ser on va parler
de dizaines maintenant parce que des
fois c'est 10 des fois c'est 13 des fois
14 dans un un délai de 10 ans
considérez-vous que SNCF réseau a
actuellement les moyens de réaliser cet
objectif plus largement comment rendre
cette ambition pleinement réalisable
quels sont les projets de CME les plus à
même d'être mis en place le plus
rapidement pouvez-vous en particulier
revenir sur l'avancée de celui de Nant
évoqué il y a quelques jours par le
ministre des Transports dans le cadre de
la polémique sur la
défaillance de de l'État dans la mise en
œuvre de la modernisation de l'aéroport
de Nantes je sais que c'est un un sujet
qui tient à cœur au sénateur retaillot
au sénateur Mandelli sur ces sujets vous
commencez déjà bénéficier du recul de
l'expérience avec des CERMES déjà
partiellement fonctionnels je pense bien
entendu à Strasbourg que nous avons eu
l'occasion avec Jacques ferernque
d'auditionner hier ainsi que Bordeaux on
le fera de mémoire demain ou
après-demain sans oublier le lément
Express quelle leçons tirez-vous de ces
laboratoires Strasbourg en particulier
grande difficulté aujourd'hui en voie de
résorption nous l'espérons sont apparus
lors du démarrage des CERMES comment
comptez-vous éviter que de tels convenus
lors de la mise en place des des autres
CERMES le cerme les CERMES ne seront pas
les premiers projets où SNCF réseau
travaillera avec un autre intervenant
sur le réseau ferré national ça a été le
cas sur la LGV tour tour Bordeaux sur
sur bretagne pays-de Loire et puis pour
le contournement de de Nice et
Montpellier ces projets ont permis SNCF
réseau d'expérimenter très concrètement
des modalités de travail avec d'autres
acteurs donc à la lumière de ces
précédents quelle est votre analyse des
dispositions de la proposition de loi
concernant les relations entre réseau et
SGP vous venez d'en parler mais on veut
encore vous entendre sur ce sujet euh
les conditions d'une bonne entente et
d'un partenariat efficace vous
sembleent-ell posé dans le texte hein
vraiment hein on se dit les choses
euh alors est-ce qu'on parle de
concurrence ou est-ce qu'on parle de
complémentarité euh notamment sur la
question des gares nouvell avec gare et
connexion mener un choc d'offre par le
biais des SERMES exige également que le
coût soit supportable pour les AOM et
les usagers à cet égard la question du
niveau des péages ferroviaires vous le
savez mieux quiconque est crucial dans
le développement des CERMES un niveau
trop élevé de péage freine les
investissements des autorités
organisatrices de mobilité dans la
mesure où les coûts de fonctionnement
futur des nouveaux projets sont trop
élevés au regard de leur capacités
financière on a également auditionné
hier que ce soit France urbaine que ce
soit région de France et et les cette
remarque est partagée par tous toutefois
nous en avons ici tous pleinement
conscience les pH ferroviaires sont
essentiels pour financer la régénération
du réseau donc on attend comme vous
probablement avec beaucoup d'attention
l'inspection générale des finances c'est
de l'environnement qui étudie ces ces
questions à travers une mission commune
pouvez-vousz déjà indiquer si ces
évolutions de la tarification des péages
ferroviaires à même de favoriser le
développement des CERMES sont envisagés
actuellement enfin dernière question si
vous me le permettez plus générale
considérez-vous que des mesures
spécifiques aux infrastructures
ferroviaires des cerme lors de leur
exploitation pourrait être envisagé dès
aujourd'hui afin de soutenir leur
développement monsieur le Président je
vous propose de répondre au rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur
euh face au au plan de charge
effectivement qui est qui est qui est
devant SNCF réseau don dont je rappelle
que que le socle pour nous c'est d'abord
la régénération et la modernisation du
réseau existant
euh j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à de
nombreuses reprises devant votre
commission à l'Assemblée si on ne
régénère pas et si on ne modernise pas
le réseau existant
euh il sera difficile d'envisager des
projets de développement que ce soit des
CERMES des projets de grande vitesse le
développement du fret ou même les
projets sur les petites lignes s'ils
aboutissaient à à déboucher sur un
réseau euh le réseau le plus le qui
reçoit le plus grand nombre de
circulation qui lui verrait sa
performance baissere ce serait un peu un
peu paradoxal donc notre premier enjeu
c'est bien toujours la régénération et
la modernisation du réseau existant avec
la perspective d'un accroissement des
investissements en la matière et ça
structure notre notre plan d'action
au-delà de ça on a on a des des blocs de
projets de développement qui sont portés
dans les contrats de projet et ta région
notamment la remise à niveau des lignes
de dessert fin du territoire euh les
CERMES les investissements en faveur du
fret et un certain nombre de projets euh
de grands projets que ce soit des grands
projets euh qui s'intègrent plutôt dans
des cadres euh comme celui des CERMES et
je pense à LNPCA ou des projets de lign
à grande vitesse euh comme euh la
liaison entre entre Bordeaux et Toulouse
euh l'enjeu pour nous c'est d'abord
d'avoir de la visibilité et je pense que
ce c'est l'enjeu pour tous les acteurs
euh industriels sans visibilité euh on
ne pour pas garantir de conduire de
manière efficace l'ensemble de ces
projets parce qu'on n'est pas
dimensionné on va pas se dimensionner
euh comme toute entreprise pour le
maximum si on n pas de visibilité si ce
maximum adviendra ou n'adviendra pas
donc on a besoin d'avoir la visibilité
sur les projets les CP vont nous donner
de la visibilité le plan qui a été mis
en mat en place en matière de frite euh
va nous donner de la visibilité la
signature et la la conclusion des
conventions de financement sur les
grands projets nous donne de la
visibilité et donc en matière de service
express régional métropolitain c'est la
même chose euh si on a de la visibilité
on sait monter en puissance on sait
embaucher des gens on sait mettre en
place des structures dédié de maîtrise
d'ouvrage et ensuite on sa'est passer
des marchés puisque je rappelle qu'en
matière d'investissement SNCF réseau
quand il investit 100 € c'est 80 € qui
sont confiés à la filière industrielle
et donc la filière industrielle elle non
plus et on le voit en matière de de
matériel roulant aussi elle non plus
elle ne sait se dimensionner que quand
elle a des commandes et donc il faut
qu'on ait de la visibilité pour pouvoir
donner de la visibilité à la filière si
on a cette visibilité on saura mettre en
place progressivement pas du jour au
lendemain si vous me dites l'année
prochaine on a 10 milliards de plus à
dépenser je vous dis on ne saura pas les
dépenser parce que on est une entreprise
industrielle si en revanche on se dit on
a une montée en charge au cours des
années 2020 pour dépenser à plein à
l'horizon 27 28 29 et bien là on saura
s'organiser avec la filière pour réussir
à la fois du côté de SNCF réseau à se
doter de ressources et du côté de la
filière à mettre en place les moyens les
moyens nécessaires d'autant plus dans un
marché de l'emploi qui est assez tendu
et sur lequel on va chercher des
ressources rares d'ingénieurs de
techniciens d'ouvriers notamment dans le
domaine de l'électricité qui sont
aujourd'hui des ressources très
concurrentiel donc on a besoin euh de
cette visibilité je pense que c'est euh
je pense que c'est la clé sur la
question du fret sur la question du fret
alors d'une part on a aujourd'hui c'est
un des domaines sur lequel de la
visibilité nous a été donné par l'État
on en aura encore plus au travers des
contrats de projet état région mais si
on fait le lien entre le fret et les
services express régionaux métropolitain
et je vous parlais tout à l'heure des
sujets d'exploitation ce sera un de nos
sujets et ce sera un des sujets sur
lequel SNCF réseau devra se faire le
gardien de l'usage collectif du bien
commun qui est le réseau ferroviaire euh
on aura la volonté de développer les
services express régionaux
métropolitains mais on aura aussi la
volonté de garder de la place pour les
trains de frite qui compte tenu de la
configuration de notre réseau traverse
nécessairement quand ils veulent
traverser toute la France sauf à les
arrêter très régulièrement traverse
nécessairement à certaines heures du
jour ou de la nuit des nœuds
ferroviaires importants dans lequel on
peut avoir la volonté de développer des
servic express régionaux métropolitain
alors ça peut être l'occasion de
construire de nouvelles infrastructures
on peut penser au contournement
ferroviaire de l'lom gération lyonnaise
par exemple mais ce sera aussi et dans
un premier temps un enjeu de garder de
la capacité pour ces trains de frit et
ça fait partie des missions qui sont
confiées à SNCF réseau et que nous
devrons exercer en expliquant et en
justifiant les choix que nous faisons
auprès des des autorités organisatrices
mais en assumant aussi qu' qu'il nous a
confié pour le bon usage du réseau le
fait de garder de la capacité pour les
pour pour pour les trains de
frite sur le fait que le le le temps
ferroviaire soit un temps long et et et
qu' faille en même temps en même temps
aller vite euh je je pense qu'on a on a
deux horizons de temps je je je le
disais il faut qu'on d'abord qu'on parte
du service et en matière de service il y
a des choses qu'on peut peut-être faire
assez vite il y a il y a rajouter des
trains alors c'est pas c'est pas
forcément évident parce qu'il faut aussi
qu'il y a les ressources du côté des
opérateurs ferroviaires il faut aussi
qui est le matériel roulant mais faire
tourner plus les trains rajouter des
trains ça peut être des choses qui
nécessitent pas d'infrastructure nouvell
et qui vont plus vite que ce qui
nécessite des infrastructures nouvelles
et en matière d'infrastructure il y a
des choses qui peuvent aller plus vite
et on peut aussi avoir des politiques de
mise en œuvre progressive c'est ce qui
se passe par exemple à bordau
aujourd'hui où on a un déploiement
progressif du service express régional
métropolitain avec tous les ans des
avancées en matière d'infrastructure on
a inauguré cette année une nouvelle une
nouvelle al qui permet de desservir un
nouveau territoire et qui permet ainsi
de développer le service express
régional métropolitain et ainsi de suite
d'année en année donc dans une politique
qui est plus une politique de
d'amélioration progressive ça n'exclut
pas qu'à certains moments au-delà de
l'amélioration progressive il faut qu'il
y ait de grandes infrastructures qui
mettent plus de temps à être constru
mais qui une fois qu'elles sont
construites changent complètement les
mobilités et et la vie des des
concitoyens les les deux sont pas
antagonistes mais on peut mener à bien
des améliorations progressives on on en
est on en est convaincu sur sur le sur
le sererme de Nantes sans rentrer trop
dans le détail ce que je peux dire c'est
que c'est un des territoires sur lequel
on travaille avec la région et avec la
métropole à à définir et notamment dans
la perspective du contrat de projet état
région qui qui qui s'ouvre des des des
un plan de déploiement du cerme et
notamment il y a eu un travail très
abouti de la région et de la métropole
euh un peu en anticipation de ce qui est
prévu dans l'article 1 du du du projet
de loi pour exprimer leur vision commune
de ce que devrait être le le le cerme de
Nantes si on fait un retour sur les sur
les sur les CERMES qui qui se sont mis
en place Strasbourg Bordeaux lément
Express j'ai dit quelques mots de
Bordeaux avec cette logique vraiment de
d'amélioration progressive d'année en
année d'augmentation progressive d'année
en année qui qui jusqu'à présent s'est
avéré être un succès sur sur Strasbourg
il faut le reconnaître du côté de
l'infrastructure les choses se sont bien
passées on a construit une 4ème voie qui
a été livrée dans les temps dans les
délais et dans un coût inférieur au coût
au coût prévu à la contractualisation
donc du point de vue de l'infrastructure
ça a été un succès mais ça montre qu'il
n'y a pas que l'infrastructure et qu'il
faut vraiment anticiper les
problématiques d'exploitation et quand
on entre dans une logique de
sererme même si on était éit très bon
avant euh une fois qu'on intensifie euh
dans la mesure dans laquelle on a
intensifié les circulations à Strasbourg
on passe à une autre échelle et il faut
vraiment que j'allais dire le le moindre
bouton de guêre le le moindre la la
moindre goutte d'huile dans les
engrenages doit être là précisément au
bon moment parce que sans ça on voit
bien qu'on a des effets en cascade et
que quand on a un train toutes les 10
minutes on sait se rattraper quand quand
on a un train toutes les 3 minutes et
bien on a beaucoup plus de mal à se
rattraper pour autant c'est une
exploitation qu'on connaît euh en
Île-de-France qui fonctionne et donc il
y a pas de raison qu'on réussisse pas à
dupliquer cette intensité de circulation
et d'ailleurs c'est l'occasion de
reparler du lément express sur le lément
Express on a mis en place ce service
avec une bascule en une nuit analogue au
mois de décembre et on n pas eu les
mêmes difficultés de rodage on avait
sans doute anticiper mieux un certain
nombre de de complexités donc voilà
l'expérience de Strasbourg c'est
vraiment une expérience qui nous dit il
faut anticiper en commun entre le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure les
opérateurs et l'autorité organisatrice
de la manière la plus aboutie possible
les les conditions d'exploitation sur le
sur le sur le sur le réseau dans les
conditions d'exploitation il y a aussi
et ça fait le lien avec le sujet des des
pH ferroviaires il y a aussi que il faut
anticiper dans les projets de cerme les
coûts de fonctionnement de ce cerme il y
a pas que les péages dans les coûts de
fonctionnement mais il y a des coûs de
fonctionnement qui peuvent être dans un
cerme augmenté de manière considérable
par rapport à la situation préexistante
puisque il faut plus de matériel roulant
du matériel roulant qui tourne plus ça
consomme de l'énergie et cetera et
cetera et donc il y a il y a il y a une
vraie anticipation et et une vraie
vision à développer avant même de
construire les infrastructures j'en
reviens toujours au au sujet il faut
avoir pensé l'ensemble des problématique
de service avant de passer aux
infrastructures il y a il y a il y a une
vraie vision des coûts d'exploitation
futur alors dans ces coups
d'exploitation il y a il y a les péages
hein c'est c'est c'est c'est certain
comme vous le disiez monsieur le
rapporteur il y a une mission de
l'Inspection Générale des Finances qui a
été lancé je les rencontre pour la
première fois demain donc je j'ai
vraiment aucune aucune information
exclusive à vous livrer sur le sur le
sur le sur le
sujet nos ressources aujourd'hui c'est
les péages ou les ou les financements
public nous nous notre enjeu c'est
d'être le plus performant possible de
coûter le moins cher possible mais une
fois qu'on coûte qu'on coûte euh il faut
couvrir il faut couvrir ses coûts et on
peut plus les couvrir par de
l'endettement puisque la loi de 2018 a
fort heureusement mis fin à
l'endettement de de de SNC à Fréau et
donc il faut les couvrir soit par des
phé soit par des subventions donc la
reconstruction de cette de cet équilibre
ou une éventuelle évolution de cet
équilibre pourra être proposé par par
par par par l'Inspection générale des
finances l'inspection générale de
l'environnement et du développement
durable je voudrais souligner que dans
la tarification et sous l'impulsion de
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
on a déjà visé à avoir une structure de
la tarification qui soit de plus en plus
sous la forme d'une part de forfait avec
des des circulations au-delà de ce
forfait qui coûte beaucoup moins cher et
et donc ça c'est une incitation au
développement du trafic de la même
manière on on on a alors ça c'est plutôt
sur les services librement organisés on
a des modulations horaire qui qui qui
permettent d'avoir des des trafics en he
creuse qui soi moins cher on a des
modulations sur les lignes de desser F
du territoire qui permettent d'inciter
au développement du trafic sur ces
lignes avec des des tarifs des tarifs
moins chers voilà c'est cette structure
de la tarification elle est favorable au
développement du trafic après il y a la
structure mais il y a le niveau et le
niveau de la tarification c'est vrai que
en France notamment sur la grande
vitesse mais aussi dans un certain
nombre de cas sur les transports du
quotidien peut être considéré comme peut
être considéré comme élevé
euh sur les autres intervenants sur le
sur le sur le réseau euh ferré national
oui on a construit des lignes à grande
vitesse en lien avec avec des
partenaires ce qu'il faut bien soigner
c'est les conventions d'interface euh
comment on construit les choses euh qui
euh construit les raccordem comment se
se font euh comment se font les
branchements ce qu'il faut bien soigner
c'est les conditions de remise de
l'infrastructure euh ses
caractéristiques son interopérabilité
avec le reste du réseau du réseau feré
national mais je je je le rappelle entre
2010 et 2017 on a construit quatre
lignes à grande vitesse selon trois
modes de réalisation différentes les
quatre ont été livrés les quatre
fonctionnent et les quatre aujourd'hui
donnent donnent satisfaction aussi bien
celle qu'on a construit en maîtrise
d'ouvrage public il faut le dire que les
deux qui ont été construites enfin les
trois qui ont été construites l'une en
concession et les deux autres en contrat
de en contrat de
partenariat le le le coût du alors
indépend je je
le l'ingénierie financière de la
construction de de ces liges c'est c'est
un autre sujet mais mais sur le plan
technique de l'exploitation et de la
qualité de la construction des
infrastructures et du fait qu'elles
aient été livrées dans les délais et
dans les coûts imaginés au moment de
leur construction sur les quatre lignes
le le le le le le succès le succès a été
a été au
rendez-vous voilà peut-être monsieur le
rapporteur ce que je pouvais indiquer en
en réponse à vos à vos questions parfait
Philippe c'est bon parfait bien je vais
donner la parole à Jacques ferdiic oui
euh donc je suis de Strasbourg donc avec
leur réseau express métropolitain
européen c'est comme ça qu'on l'a appelé
Strasbourg le Grand Est avec la SNCF ont
ouvert la série l'expérience est
précieuse vous l'avez dit elle a
massivement oui augmenté l'offre
ferroviaire en cherchant à tirer parti
au au mieux des améliorations de
capacité de la dorsal ferrovire
alsacienne principalement en droit de
l'agglomération de Strasbourg un tronçon
de 4e voie qui a permis l'essentiel donc
aujourd'hui il y a des centaines de
trains supplémentaires un exemple vers
2000 pour rentrer chez moi le soir
c'était 19h20 et en général je le ratais
parce que j'arrivais trop tard
aujourd'hui c'est 22h37 voilà et il y en
a plein entre 19h et 22h37 il y en a pas
qu'un euh alors on on a l'habitude de
parler de choc d'offre là on en a les
ingrédients le problème c'est que le
choc a pas été tout à fait celui que
nous visions parce que la mise en place
a été chaotique et c'est pas fini pas à
hauteur attendue la SNCF a pas été en
mesure d'assurer ce qu'elle s'était dite
capable de faire hein vous venez de dire
qu'il fallait parfois admettre ce qui
n'était pas possible là clairement on
est d'accord ça a pas été correctement
défini et il y a plein de boutons de
guêre qui ont sauté hein c'était pas
impeccable les cascades de retard
d'annulation ont vite figé l'opinion des
usagers et surtout des usagers
potentiels et pour les usagers déjà
acquis ça les a sacrément mécontenté
voir découragé encore là récemment j'ai
échanger avec des habitants de la vallée
de la Bruche les mécontentements
l'emportent encore sur les satisfactions
hein c'est la ligne Strasbourg Épinal
qui a été rétabli donc il y a une nette
amélioration sur cette ligne avant à
l'arrivée à la frontière Loren c'était
un terminus pour l'essentiel ceci dit
c'est une ligne donc SNCF réseau encore
à régénérer et à moderniser fortement
au-delà de molshheim euh depuis le mois
d'août donc réseau express métropolitain
européen depuis le mois d'août
paradoxalement il y a plus de train
transfrontaliers entre mulouse et mulim
hein c'est c'est un quart et que ça soit
un contrecoup des difficultés du Réseau
Express métropolitain de l'agglomération
de Strasbourg ça semble évident alors
devant nous on a aussi des
investissements très conséquent sur la
ligne très dégradée vers le nord
Strasbourg loterbourg sansela c'est
toute une partie de l'agglomération sens
large de Strasbourg qui ne pourra avoir
rien de plus comme desserte et qui a
très mal vécu le fait de de de voir des
agglomérations de des améliorations de
dessertes annoncé partout sauf pour eux
hein et c'est pas rien donc on est sur
le réseau existance et donc plutôt vous
qui agirez pour l'essentiel quoi que le
grand test a déjà mis laasgp dans la
boucle ils ont une délibération qui
passe ce jeudi le COI dans son rapport a
chiffré alors je sais pas sur quoi il
s'est basé exactement à 500 millions ce
qui resterait à faire pour que le cerme
de Strasbourg soit totalement abouti un
chiffre d'autant plus vertigineux qu' a
pas de trajectoire financière visible
donc on va voir un texte cadrant les
Chermes les dispositions qu'il prévoit
celle qu'on peut encore y mettre
aurait-elle été utile pour mieux réussir
le REM strasbourgeois comment selon vous
rattraper ce mauvais départ éviter de
reproduire de tels déconvenus faire en
sorte que pour nos concitoyens le REM et
les CERMES qui suivont soi perçus
d'abord comme
positif merci je je je vous remercie de
de rester dans le thème de ce jour euh
je vais donner la parole à iivier
Jacquin
merci président euh monsieur Chabanel on
peut louer ce texte de loi qui parle de
développement ferroviaire ce que l'on
attend tous et la transition climatique
l'attend mais on peut faire le constat
en même temps que le nouveau pacte
ferroviaire a empêché SNCF réseau de
faire du développement ferroviaire on a
été unanime dans cette commission pour
condamner le contrat de performance
comme l'a signalé l'art le contrat de
performance qui va voir une dégradation
du réseau ferroviaire existant et on n'a
pas obtenu encore satisfaction sur ce
point-là et d'un autre côté vous êtes
empêché d'investir vous l'avez rappelé
très rapidement il y a une règle d'or
qui briille l'investissement à SNCF
réseau et je pense je pose la question
directement plutôt que de lancer un
nouvel opérateur est-ce qu'il faut pas
redonner un peu plus de marge de
manœuvre à SNCF réseau devant l'ENS
emble des injonctions contradictoires
qui sont devant vous c'est ma question
essentielle la la seconde c'est sur la
pénurie de personnel spécialisé vous
n'avez plus le statut à SNCF réseau et
là vous avez SGP qui est sur une
structure beaucoup plus légère et
beaucoup plus facile et qui fonctionne
en mode projet à échéance rapide comment
dans ce contexte vous pouvez fidéliser
vos équipes les plus
pointues actuellement je vous
remercie si je vais don la parole à
Denise
SAÉ merci monsieur le Président d'abord
je veux m'excuser auprès du de philippe
Tabarot notre collègue en lui disant que
je vais un peu parler de mon département
et que l'ensemble des départements font
la France c'est tout ce que je voulais
dire à Monsieur tabarou et
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
euh vous m'avez un peu rassuré avec
votre première phrase votre objectif
c'est la régénération et la
modernisation du réseau existant euh il
n'empêche que j'ai envie de vous dire
qu'au sud de Bordeaux c'est encore la
France et que je veux moi vous parler de
la ligne historique pyrénéenne euh et
vous devez connaître son état parce que
l'ensemble des caténir qui composent
cette ligne qui remonte souvent dans
leur construction remonte souvent à 1920
et rien n'a été fait depuis cette
époque-là donc très régulièrement et
vous le savez vous êtes informé la
presse en parle régulièrement il ne se
passe pas une semaine sans que les
trains soient en rade les usagers
restent en Caraf et cette situation est
absolument intolérable don moi ma
première question monsieur le PDG c'est
de vous dire bon en êtes-vous conscient
et et que faites-vous et où en êtes-vous
de la modernisation de cette ligne et
puis je vous dirais à défaut d'avancer
sur ce chantier une issue salutaire
serait de désenclaver le bassin chalos B
bigor via le RER pyrénéen ce projet ne
fait cependant pas partie des dossiers
qui ont été rendus prioritaires pas dans
le rapport du comité d'orientation des
infrastructures alors à votre avis
monsieur le PDG comment pouvons-nous
faire avancer au plus vite cette
initiative de manière à ce qu'elle
puisse s'inscrire dans la dynamique des
CERMES je vous
remercie
merci je je soutiens ce que dit Philippe
tabarou entendra à une audition monsieur
Chabanel effectivement on pourra
effectivement poser un petit peu de
question sur sur ce qui nous concerne
directement dans nos secteur mais là je
qu'il faut qu'on reste sur effectivement
ces CERMES et puis la réponse sur
comment ça s'inclut dedans pourquoi pas
mais sinon on peut pas répondre à
systématiquement sur ce sujet parce que
c'est bien la PPL qu'on est en train de
préparer dont philippe Tabarot est le
rapporteur je remercie d'avoir fait
cette précision euh Franck versin oui
oui monsieur le Président vous pourriez
passer une semaine d'audition ici que
nous n'en auons pas encore assez donc ça
viendra j'en suis certain en plusieurs
fois le le projet de loi prévoit donc la
la possibilité de de pouvoir confier à
la SGP donc la responsabilité de la
construction des gares qui
n'exploiteront pas
hein alors que bon SNCF réseau et gar
connexion c'est parfaitement géré cela
donc comment
percevez-vous cela et
puis oui on l'a dit tout à l'heure au
président
monta ces CMEs ne peuvent pas réussir
sir s'il n'y a pas un travail main dans
la main en totale concertation avec SNCF
réseau alors vous l'avez dit également
vous manquez de moyens et et et les
travaux qu'il qui qui doivent être fait
en tout cas en terme de de personnel
sont tels sur les CERMES que finalement
l'aide de la GP est plutôt quelque chose
de d'approprié mais on reste inquiet sur
justement
cette
capacité aux équipes de bien travailler
ensemble parce que la IGP ne peut pas
réussir sans sans je dirais les gens de
SNCF réseau qui qui connaissent sur le
bout des doigts le le réseau et qui
savent le faire fonctionner voilà merci
merci est-ce que avant que je donne la
parole au président est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres questions sur ce cette PPL il
n'y en a pas ben monsieur le Président
vous avez la parole merci
alors d'abord pour pour répondre à la
question de Monsieur
[Musique]
fernck sur
Strasbourg je je pense qu'effectivement
par rapport à ce qu'il y a dans la PPL
aujourd'hui le fait de de de pointer
dans la proposition de loi le fait qu'on
ait contractualisé l'offre de service
qu'on devait faire ce qui
responsabilise les les les opérateurs le
fait de suivre dans la durée de manière
précise entre le moment où où on s'est
dit on va construire cette
infrastructure pour faire l'offre de
service et et l'offre de service qu'on
veut mettre à la fin voilà tout ce cadre
qui peut paraître peut-être un peu
pesant à mon avis est très bénéfique
dans un mode comme le ferroviaire qui
est un mode quand même très réglé par
nature et dans lequel quand on essaie
d'apporter des variations ça peut avoir
des conséquences en effet cascade qu'on
ne maîtrise pas toujours donc il me
semble que le cadre qui est posé dans la
dans la proposition de loi peut
faciliter euh d'éviter les écueils comme
comme celui qu'on a conduit à Strasbourg
là là où je vous rejoins c'est
qu'effectivement quand on rencte des
difficultés comme ça même si la
situation se rétabliss qui est en place
aujourd'hui la la perception de la
dégradation met beaucoup beaucoup plus
de temps à à à être à être corrigé que
elle ne met à s'instaler donc voilà on a
un vrai enjeu de réussir dès le départ
voilà de de pas avoir des premières
étapes des premières étapes difficiles
par parce que même si on les rattrape
après c'est autant de de temps de perdu
et puis d'inscription dans et on peut le
comprendre on le vit tous comme ça nous
aussi dans dans dans dans les dans les
esprits euh sur le sur
le l'exemple que vous donnez fait fait
bien le lien avec les besoins du réseau
existant c'est-à-dir euh on ne pourra
pas construire des services express
régionaux métropolitain efficace et et
on voit bien qu'on on est très vite
confronté à à une difficulté à augmenter
l'offre si on n pas régénéré et
modernisé le réseau sur lesquel ces
services se se se mettent en place alors
dans le dans le cas de la région
grandest on va être dans une situation
un peu spécifique puisque la région
grandantest a choisi de faire de mettre
en œuvre l'article 172 de la de la loi
d'orientation sur la mobilité donc de
demander le transfert de gestion d'un
certain nombre de de ces de ces de ces
lignes donc elle sera pleinement
responsable de leur de leur régénération
et de leur modation mais mais plus
généralement je je je pense important de
bien mettre en en perspective les
travaux qu'on fera en matière de
régénération des travaux qu'on fera en
matière de de développement de de
développement de l'offre
[Musique]
h sur les sur les sujets soulevés par
par par par Monsieur Jacquin
euh moi je n'ai pas de regret qu'on ait
mis fin la capacité financière de SNCF
réseau à s'endetter
euh ça ça ça pose au moins les sujets
sur la table euh j'allais dire la la
capacité d'endettement de SNCF réseau
c'était un moyen de ne pas traiter les
sujets et puis de les traiter dans la
douleur au bout de 20 ou 25 ans au
moment où on vient faire une reprise de
dette de 35 milliards de 35 milliards
d'euros qui qui qui nous a quand même
remise à flot et qui nous redonne des
perspective et donc recréer une capacité
à s'endetter parce que on ne veut pas
mettre soit la subvention publiqu soit
des péages je je pense que ce serait
quand même une échappatoire dont dans
quelques années on viendrait nous dire
qu'elle était qu'elle avait été une
solution de de de de de facilité donc ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas qu'on
travaille à l'ingénierie financière
qu'on pas qu'on travaille aux modalités
de financement d'ailleurs la Société du
Grand Paris demain société des grands
projets peut amener cette ingénierie
financière peut amener ces ces ces ces
leviers là euh mais voilà je pense que
du point de vue de SNC réseau qui est
d'abord une entreprise dont le cœur de
métier c'est chaque jour de faire rouler
15000 trains en toute sécurité sur le
réseau le fait de pas être une
entreprise durablement endettée et et et
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui est très
est très est très
bénéfique sur le le sujet très essentiel
des ressources humaines pour mener à
bien ces projets parce que ces projets
ils ne seront menés à bien que si on a
les compétences pour pour pour pour les
faire euh aujourd'hui du alors je je je
je je reste prudent mais on a vu une
inflexion du côté de SNC Réau au travers
de notre politique de recrutement qui
nous a permis de sortir de la crise
qu'on a connu postérieurement à la crise
sanitaire en 2021 on était vraiment dans
une situation extrêmement tendue sur le
recrutement qui faisait qu'on ne on ne
réussissait pas à couvrir indépendamment
de la contrainte budgétaire normale dans
toute entreprise on ne réussissait pas à
couvrir les postes que l'on ouvrait sur
le marché du travail cette année à la
fin du mois de de juin on a recruté à
SNCF réseau 80 % de personnes en plus
qu'à la fin du mois de juin 2022 donc
grâce à une politique très active sur le
recrutement grâce à une accélération de
nos procédures de recrutement grâce à
une une une analyse assez fine des des
attentes du du du marché on a on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation qui est
beaucoup plus favorable qu'elle n'était
par le passé ça ça ne nous met pas à la
fin de de l'histoire parce queensuite
ces personnes qu'on recrute il faut
qu'on les forme et il faut qu'on les
fidélise pour qu'il ne pour qu'il ne
nous quittent pas donc ça ça nous oblige
à avoir une politique salariale une
politique de qualité de vie au travail
une politique de de rétention des
talents que qui soit plus dynamique que
celle qu'on avait par le passé mais mais
j'allais dire sur le recrutement on a
aujourd'hui en tout cas en 2023 fait des
progrès importants dont on vise de les
de les maintenir ir dans la durée plus
généralement ça pose la question et
c'est vrai pour nous c'est vrai pour la
Société du Grand Paris et c'est vrai
pour toute la filière industrielle de
comment et et et c'est un travail de
sensibilisation qu'on essaie d'aller
faire dès le collège dès le lycée parce
que on recrute aussi bien des ouvriers
des techniciens des ingénieurs comment
on oriente les jeunes hommes et femmes
vers des métiers techniques vers des
filières technique aussi bien dans les
métiers d'opérateurs dans les métiers de
techniciens dans les métiers
d'ingénieurs je pense que c'est un défi
pour toute la société mais pour une
grande entreprise industrielle comme la
nôtre c'est vraiment un défi qu'on qu'on
qu'on prend à plein et sur lequel on
essaie de sensibiliser dès dès leur plus
enfin dès le dès le collège et dès le
lycée à ces orientations là parce que
les métiers de la transition énergétique
et du transport seront des métiers dans
lequels on aura besoin de personnes qui
auront fait des des études des études
techniques notamment euh s'agissant
s'agissant de de je je reviens pas sur
la sur la modernisation de la ligne
historique pyénéen même si j'y suis très
attaché et et et la la caténire midi
devra être changé ça renvoie à ce besoin
de régénération et de modernisation ça a
été la première priorité qui a été donné
par la première ministre dans ses
annonces du mois de février ça reste
pour moi la première priorité parce que
c'est c'est bien parce qu'on fera ces
travaux-l qu'on a fait sur la voix sur
cette ligne hein c'est pas une ligne
qu'on a qu'on a délaissé aujourd'hui on
a beaucoup moins d'incidents en matière
de voie sur cette ligne il faut qu'on
fasse la même chose sur la kn faut qu'on
fasse la même chose sur la signalisation
parce que c'est sera ça la condition de
développement du service ensuite sur la
la capacité à développer un cerme dans
le bassin chalos Bern bigor bah la la la
proposition de loi va fixer un cadre de
coopération entre régions les
agglomérations pour faire des
propositions une éligibilité qui sera
ensuite soumise à soumise à l'état et et
donc il y a un cadre qui sera défini et
qui laissera ensuite aux acteurs locaux
et nationaux l'occasion de de développer
de développer un ser sur les la la la
coopération avec la Société du Grand
Paris alors d'abord moi j'ai j'ai pas
peur de dire que SNCF réseau c'est faire
des lignes nouvelles et SNCF réseau
c'est faire des gares nouvelles avec
SNCF gare et connexion voilà on et c'est
faire des lignes nouvelles et des gares
nouvelles de qualité la gare nouvelle
qu'on a construite et qui sera en
service au au printemps 2024 sous le
knit à la défense sans avoir arrêté
l'exploitation du knit c'est un exploit
technique qui aujourd'hui dans l'Europe
voire dans le monde entier est considéré
à sa à sa à à sa juste valeur donc voilà
il a il y a de la compétence chez SNCF
réseau et SNCF gare et connexion sur ces
sujetsl pour autant moi je pense que
dans les domaines techniques il est
toujours
intéressant d'avoir des points de vue
différents euh et donc avoir l'apport de
la Société du Grand Paris sur un certain
nombre de projets qu'un certain nombre
de projets leur soit confiés ça peut
permettre de faire progresser le système
en grand ça peut permettre de le faire
progresser en grand d'abord parce que en
terme de capacité d'ingénierie et ben on
sera plus nombreux à agir et ça peut
aller permettre d'aller plus vite vous
le soullignez monsieur le rapporteur on
a l'enjeu d'aller plus vite mais ça peut
aussi amener des idées qu'on n pas eu
forcément à SNCF réseau et donc amener
un un panorama de solutions qui soit qui
soit plus large donc là-dessus je pense
qu'il y a il y a voilà il il y a
vraiment le chemin pour une
complémentarité ce qu'il faut absolument
éviter et et et j'allais dire c'est
c'est c'est j'ai j'ai une ancienneté qui
qui me permet dans dans le secteur de de
de de parler pour l'avoir vécu C cette
situation là c'est c'est c'est d'avoir
des règles du jeu qui ne soient pas
claires et et ça a pu être le cas à une
époque entre RFF
SNCF où chacun voulait progressivement
recouvrer le périmètre de l'autre ou ne
voulez pas lâcher son périmètre
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de l'autre
aujourd'hui je je dans la relation
vraiment de qualité qu'on a avec
Jean-François monteis moi je j'ai jamais
entendu dire et je pense pas qu'il vous
l'ai dit qu'il avait envie d'aller
exploiter d'aller maintenir des
infrastructures qu'il aurait qu'il
aurait qu'il aurait construite il vous a
dit donc voilà donc on est on est
vraiment vraiment et et donc les les les
règles qui ont qui sont posées dans la
proposition de loi elles me permettent
de de penser et en tout cas on œuvrera
au quotidien pour cela que on n' pas les
mêmes risques de dérive de concurrence
entre deux entités publiques qui
viendrai se tirer dans les pattes et
aboutir à des dysfonctionnements mais
vraiment un enjeu de coopération et de
et de complémentarité alors ça ça
passera aussi par les hommes et par les
femmes sur le terrain il faut il faut il
faut le dire on est des on est des
entreprises qui sont des entreprises qui
marchent d'abord par les hommes et par
les femmes qui sont qui sont sur le
terrain donc là il y aura un enjeu de
bonne coopération de bon état d'esprit
mais je pense que si cet enjeu il est
impulsé par la loi et en ensite impulsé
par les équipes de direction des deux
entreprises il y a pas de raison qu'on
le retrouve pas au quotidien sur le
terrain et et je ne doute pas que les
autorités organisatrices régional et
métropolitaines seront attentives à ce
qui est c cet enjeu de coopération et
nous notre premier enjeu c'est de
développer le ferroviaire et pour cela
de satisfaire les attentes des autorités
organisatrices régionales comme comme
métropolitaines donc on a notre intérêt
objectif il est à la coopération dans le
jeu dans le jeu
d'actant
je pense avoir fait le tour des
questions bien puisque sil n'y a plus de
question mais je vais lever la séance en
remerciant monsieur le Président
Directeur Général de SNCF réseau pour
son écoute et ses réponses merci de
votre
participation et j'ai une information à
vous donner dès que j'aurai raccompagné
P monsieur
ch
dernier conduit un cycle d'audition
danse complété par nos travaux de ce
matin en plainère la PPL ou desb qui le
rapporteur Franck dersin avec de
nombreuses auditions qui seront
enrichies par celles de Valérie pcrè en
pleinère cet
après-midi et enfin la PPL réemploie des
véhicules déposés par notre ancien
collègue Joël Labé inscrite dans la
niche du groupe écologiste et qui
pourrait être examiné en séance publique
le 13 décembre prochain sous réserve de
son inscription à l'ordre du jour
plusieurs initiatives gouvernementales
sont par ailleurs à prévoir avec un
degré de certitude plus ou moins for à
ce stade j'évoquerai à cet égard le
projet de loi proposant une fusion entre
l'ASN et l'IRSN qui pourrait être
examiné au Sénat en 2e
lieu à partir de la mi-janvier le projet
de loi programmation énergie climat
annoncé pour 2000 décembre 2023 mais
dont le dépôt n'est pas certain le
projet de loi d'orientation agricole qui
pourra contenir des mesures sur l'eau
euh qui concerne notre commission
pouvant justifier une saisine pour avis
le calendrier et le contenu ne sont
toutefois pas encore précisés et enfin
le projet de loi programmation dans le
domaine des transports dont l'examen
n'est pas encore confirmé par le
gouvernement bien qu'il a engagé des
concertations le bureau a également acté
le principe de la désignation de H
rapporteurs budgétaires sous réserve de
validation du périmètre de la sésine
pour avis qui interviendra la
désignation la semaine prochaine je vous
informe que les crédits de la mission
recherche enseignement supérieur dans le
domaine du développement durable seront
désormais examinés dans le cadre des
avis techniques pour assurer une
expertise expertise plus cohérente et
donner une plus grande visibilité aux
travaux des rapporteurs budgétaires ces
rapporteurs de budgétaires comme je vous
l'ai indiqué seront désignés la semaine
prochaine en application du présent du
principe de la représentation
proportionnelle les auditions
budgétaires sont un des temps forts de
l'année pour la Commission et permettent
de faire le point avec les ministres
compétents sur les secteurs stratégique
de la commission pour plus de détails je
vous invite à vous reporter au
calendrier prévisionnel qui vous est
envoyé périodiquement et qui sera mis à
jour une fois le calendrier budgétaire
connu en ce qui concerne les travaux de
contrôle de notre commission l'actualité
et les priorités politique ont conduit
le bureau à décider la mise en place de
deux missions d'information interne à
notre commission je vous propose
d'actter la mise en place d'une mission
flash pour examiner la situation de
l'aéroport de Nant Atlantique à la suite
du revirement du gouvernement qui a
récemment annulé l'appel d'offre qui
visait à renouveler la concession et à à
moderniser cette infr structure alors
que ce même gouvernement s'était engagé
après l'abandon du projet d'aéroport de
NotreDame des Landes en 2018 à mener à
bien ce chantier avec diligence je vous
propose donc d'approuver la création de
cette mission flash pour laquelle un
rapporteur sera désigné également la
semaine prochaine afin de lancer nos
travaux plus vite et rendre nos
conclusions avant la fin de l'année la
question de l'accès à l'égalité des
soins sur notre territoire reste une
question entière et une question et
mérite que la mission poursuivre ses
investigations dans le cadre de sa
compétence en matière d'aménagement du
territoire dans la continuité de nos
travaux menés en 2022 sous la conduite
de son excellent rapporteur que je salue
Bruno rejoint et des propositions
législatives qui en ont résulté cette
mission pourrait d'ailleurs donner lieu
à un déplacement en Allemagne pour voir
quelles réponses ont été apportées à
cette problématique outrerin là encore
je vous propose d'approuver la mise en
place de cette mission qu'on pourrait
qualifier de droite de suite à nos
travaux dans l'attente de de la
désignation